we've been talking all morning about gay
marriage yesterday though was the
Obamacare case and with that out of the
way the great health care consolidation
of 2015 can officially begin or continue
and it might continue this weekend
Aetna's on the verge of a deal to buy a
rival Humana nekkid set off a wave of
deal-making Bloomberg's drew Armstrong
covers the industry for us so drew what
should we be keeping our eyes on well
it's really interesting what's happening
that we've been you know as you know
well in this period of all these drug
companies buying each other right one
writes been really quiet has been the
insurance industry and the hospital in
street then all of a sudden in the last
few weeks we've seen every single one of
the big five in the insurance industry
looking at it seems like buying every
single else in the big five we're
probably go from a big five down to a
big three okay we've had this thing with
humana floating out there we think that
cigna is probably in play and one way
another yeah well here we go let's take
a look at this [ __ ] you got it United
right so the United is the big yep
they're the giant and they were made
they're gonna remain one of the three no
matter what happens yeah what about
anthems and because they want to buy
anthem is on the prowl they've been
looking at cigna right it doesn't want
to get bought okay heard something about
Aetna and Humana um there's a
possibility that Humana could maybe go
and play to somebody else maybe Cigna
now looks for something they don't get
wanna get bought by anthem do they look
at Aetna do they talk to Humana about
combining together in some sort of
merger of equals I mean everybody here
right now is in play all right well
everyone is in play this has got to be
good news for the investment bankers in
the banking industry i'm gonna try to
bring five down to three that means a
lot of things a lot of folks are
probably gonna make a lot of money on
these deals are their characteristics
that tell you that one is gonna be a
takeover candidate versus another you
know the health insurance industry is
actually really fascinating we look at
these huge companies but in fact they're
really regional businesses most of the
time they may only be inside you know a
dozen or two dozen states so you're not
necessarily buying for synergy or
anything like that as much as you're
buying to be in different markets that
you're not I want to get bigger you want
scale and right now with these Obama
care subsidies protected by the court
yesterday that means that those millions
of new customers are gonna continue to
come in and buy coverage with financial
help from the government you want to be
in those markets where they're out
and capture those new customers so who's
got the best profile in terms of
Medicare payments let's just start there
you know Humana has a lot of Medicare
Advantage business that's one of the
reasons that they are you know they're
very popular for that reason it's a fast
growing program you got more Americans
who are turning 65 they're entering the
Medicare program Medicare Advantage the
private sector version the government
pays insurers to essentially run a
private version of Medicare a lot of
growth there it's one of those big
demographic trends that's really helping
the industry all right now if these
deals do indeed go through i'm assuming
that they get some kind of Federal Trade
Commission some kind of anti monopoly on
the consideration one of the things that
we've been hearing from folks is it the
first deal to go through is probably
gonna be easy second deal may not be
quite so easy so it's a rush to see who
can be the first one here you know you
don't want to have the FTC breathing
down your neck after they look at the
first deal and say oh man well now we've
got four of these do we really want to
just go to three you want to get it done
and get it done fast reminds me a little
of what goes on in the telecom industry
or indeed the mobile phone industry who
are the big players when it comes to the
advisors or the personalities involved
in all you know we actually there's so
many of these of the companies that are
involved here we pretty much have most
of the major banks I think we have all
the big advisory firms in the
communications side everybody's paired
up with somebody else everybody has been
getting mixed up in this right now as
busy as we are is there any fight
between the potential acquirer and they
acquire in terms of who would then run
the company that is put together this
anthem and Cigna letter exchange we had
of last weekend is delightful and
interesting both CEOs seem to want to be
in charge we've had so you know anthem
CEO said hey I'll step down after two
years you'll be in this great position
the other guy was basically I you know I
want you to guarantee me the job and
nobody seems that seems to be the big
sticking point here he's over who's
gonna actually run this company if they
do a deal less so than price who wants
to be the top dog everybody right
everybody wants to run a company well
done all right you're gonna keep us
up-to-date oh thanks very much
Bloomberg's true Armstrong